so as she said I've been working in this
field for about four or five years the
past couple I've been freelance and I
would not I would also not consider
myself an expert at natural language
processing I'd say I've used it
occasionally in different projects that
I've done both professionally and for
fun but I'm still I guess I'd say I'm
intermediate in my theory my
understanding of theory that said I
chose I chose this talk because I wanted
an excuse to learn more about word
embeddings and algorithmic fairness so
I'm gonna try and take you along like
the journey that I took over the past
couple months and just what I learned so
the hope is I can jump-start all of you
to get to a place where you feel more
comfortable with those concepts so I
first this first came to my attention
when I started seeing like this type of
stuff in my Twitter stream oh yeah on
the previous slide I should have pointed
out for emphasis the slides all the
slides and all the code I talk about is
up in that github repo okay in this in
this slide we see something I saw more
and more in my Twitter timeline and this
person just trained word Tyvek weird
embedding using Google News Corvis and
they were just playing around with
analogies and they got some pretty
misogynistic results so in case you
can't read it on the top it says she is
too persuasive as he is too eloquent
cogent forceful compelling persuasive
all these wonderful positive synonyms
for persuasive and then they tried the
opposite he is too persuasive as she is
too unpersuasive seductive motherly
ditzy manipulative like I I was blown
away by that like I at the time I had
some idea of I had a good idea of how
were to vet worked like what it was a
vector representation of words and kind
of
coding semantics meeting and seeing that
it was trained on you know something
that wasn't openly misogynistic and
racist I wouldn't think that like really
blew me away and so that was just
someone playing around with the word
embedding I also started seeing stuff
like in production so API is that people
were using this is an example from the
perspectives API and this person just
started hitting the API with different
text and the point of it was the API
gives you back a percentage of toxicity
and this API was trained on Wikipedia
Talk pages and it's being used I think
it's still being used now by the New
York Times to help them automate their
content moderation their comment
moderation so it's just being used to
flag toxic comments on their web pages
for manual review but when this person
entered in these like identity phrases
they got some pretty concerning results
as far as one group versus another I
also saw it wasn't just one API it was
lots of sentiment stuff and the various
flavors of sentiment so across religious
groups they saw different different
positive and negative sentiment and I
also started to see lots of translations
translation errors and there's we've
always been translation fails but I
started to see stuff powered I assume by
neural translation and this specific one
context mattered so on the left there is
neutral and positive contexts where the
characters above were translated as
black foreigner and on the right there
were negative context you got the racial
slur so there's also other translation
examples I saw a bunch of that where you
went from a gender neutral phrase or
sentence and after running it through
the translator you got a gen
phrase according to like a stereotype so
in order to build your intuition for why
some of these things were happening
who here has I want to get a feel for
like how comfortable the audience is
with word embeddings who here is used
word embeddings and a project before Jim
maybe like half the people how many know
how a word embedding is trained like the
free pre trained embeddings ok maybe
like a third so do a bit of a review for
word embeddings it's a dense
representation of words the idea for
them was around since like the 1950s and
it's only practically been implemented
in the last 10 years or so most of the
the word embeddings i've heard about are
a hidden layer that was trained as part
of another neural network in which the
task was to predict words near other
words so it's it's all based off of Cork
co-occurrence counts people toss around
the phrase like you will know a word by
the neighbor
it keeps or the company it keeps
basically it's like the neural
equivalent of latent semantic analysis
or like doing us singular value
decomposition there's other techniques
but it's it's one of the hidden layers
from from a neural network that you then
repurpose as an embedding layer for
other models so by the end of this talk
I hope that like me you'll have a better
idea of why some of the examples I
showed up top happen and I hope you'll
be able to recognize when something you
are building is at risk of generating
something similar
like bad results and I hope you'll have
lots of ideas about what you can do
about it so I after like finding all
those examples and submitting a talk
proposal to here I really let her fire
me on lit a fire under me to just start
researching stuff the first thing that I
noticed was people were defining
particularly the word bias in many
different ways so when I said prejudice
in my talk I'm using one of the papers
I'll talk about defines it this way as
unwanted bias and bias itself was really
problematic like I found lots of
articles particularly with like
technical people in the field
complaining about how journalists were
covering some of those bad examples I
showed up top and what that bias was so
I just want to like disambiguate bias
from like bias-variance tradeoff or how
a statistician would define bias like
the average print like distance from the
average prediction to the true parameter
some of the more technical complaints
about the journal the journalism on
those articles was that the journalist
was complaining about the distance of
the average prediction not from the true
parameter but from an idealized
parameter and I was actually okay with
that like I think this quote really
struck home for me with that in mind and
the ultimate goal is not building
machines that think like humans but
designing machines that help humans
think better like I think we should be
held up to the same standard that some
of those stories focused on and not like
you can have an accurate you can
accurately represent that bias for what
exists in the real world but we have an
opportunity to try and optimize to the
ideal so going forward I'm using like
the common definition of bias that most
people on the street would use
I also found this one paper this one
article by the Microsoft design team
that kind of bucketed some examples of
bias and examples I showed up top are an
example of Association bias as described
in this article and that's when data is
used to train a model that reinforces
and multiplies cultural bias I do
recommend that article it's a nice
grouping of different types of bias so
another thing I started seeing more and
more as I researched was this in my
initial research this was the most
commonly cited source and it is a paper
in which they adapt the implicit
association test to word embeddings and
what that gets you is it lets you
quantify the unwanted bias a specific
unwanted bias and it'll give you an
effect size and a significance level not
all so this paper in general just gives
a really excellent it does an excellent
job at putting the problem in
perspective and asking bigger picture
questions beyond just the technical
questions of who decides which biases
are unwanted and calling out the need
for other methods to be employed besides
just the detecting and removal that
we'll talk about another paper that was
highly cited was was this one by toga of
olive bossy and others but in this paper
they described a way to remove specific
biases by determining which which of
like of the many dimensions a word
omitting has which specific dimensions
or some combination thereof represent a
particular bias they they showed that
they could collapse
collapse words in that combination of
dimensions so you can visualize this a
little better this is an example from
another paper where they are doing the
actual devising and what you see is this
these are the two principal components
of gender so on the Left it's more male
and on the right it's more female so if
a word in the bottom left it's baseball
Kings rugby lions he gaffer on the right
is female there's there's princess up
here so what they've done is they've
they've run a principal components
analysis on a warden bedding and these
are the top two components that explain
gender and then so that's like the
subspace that encodes gender over all
the words and then they've tried to
collapse that I can't see but in the on
the x-axis right in the middle here is
zero so that means it's not encoding
male or female and for although all the
words that should be gender-neutral but
won't if they're biased like
receptionist or manager or babysitter
they've tried to move them to the middle
of these two dimensions in the word
embedding but they've tried to leave
gender where it's appropriate like
grandmother or sister so for all the
words that they thought were appropriate
they didn't move them and the
gender-neutral ones got squished in so
that's what I mean by collapsed the sub
space of that particular bias and the
embedding
so the author of that nanostick computer
as computer programmer paper
Tolga he has a github repo in which he
ran his hard des biasing method on word
to vector aend on Google News so you can
you can play with a device that betting
in terms of gender and he posted an
implementation of that de biasing code
and then Rob spear and the people at
concept net they also have a pre trained
in writing that they put out called
number batch and what they did was take
it a step further and instead of just
doing it for gender they did racial
stereotypes and ethnic stuff they
removed lots of different biases here's
some stats from number batch so they
compared all these different embeddings
blue blues work Tyvek then you got
oranges glove another renormalized glove
and at the the last two purple is their
number batch before they biased before
they ran d biasing and the brown columns
these last ones are after they ran their
d biasing code they did i don't think
they did the same exact implementation
that i'm told i did with last word to
Veck one but they showed improvements
and they measured these correlation to
stereotypes a little bit differently to
they didn't use wheat they trained a
they trained uh I think they trained a
sentiment classifier and they tried
different groups against it so I also
recommend this article by also by Rob's
beer so I encountered this before I saw
before I knew about the other
pre-trained embeddings
this article also has really great
examples of testing for bias in a
statistically rigorous way so I wanted
to try that word embedding Association
test from that first paper on some of
these other embeddings like particularly
the one that was hardly biased for
gender by Alec Bosque at all and I also
want to try it on the number of actual
and that had been D biased but there was
no implementation of wheat I could find
and at this point I really identify with
this particular addition of this mean of
fake O'Reilly books so I just started
writing code I started implementing the
word embedding Association tests and
I'll give an overview of how the test
works I'm not going to walk through the
through the code too much because I
think there's some other more valuable
things to walk talk about but the
general way that the we works is you get
a group of target words where these are
groups of words you wish to test for the
unwanted bias in and then you get your
attribute words to groups each so to
test for gender bias one groups man one
group's female and you get lots of
examples of those words and the null
hypothesis of the test is that there's
no difference between the two sets of
target words and their relative
similarity to the two sets of attribute
words so in our example to pick out
individual words it's saying male is
about the same male teacher is about the
same as male nurse
as far as as far as cosine similarity
goes and then to put to put a p-value
like significance on it you should be
able to if that null hypothesis is true
you should be able to mix up the
groupings of target words and that's the
crux of how they're doing the stats for
this it's a permutation test so they're
just mixing up the two target groups and
every
possible way so to compare for each word
in our target group they're going to
compare the difference between that
target word and each of the groups of
attributes and then they're going to do
that for every word in each of the
target groups it's all it's all based
off of cosine similarity and just
summing and averaging pretty much so
this gives you a test statistic and then
you do that for your original grouping
of how I first laid out this example and
then when you do that for the original
grouping you can calculate anis an
effect size which is pretty much using
your groupings things a little
differently instead of summing you're
taking the mean and then you're just
normalizing it to see how big an effect
or quantifying the amount of bias and
this particular grouping and then to get
a significance level you're just going
to see how common it is if you mix up
those those words and that in the target
groupings you're going to calculate that
T statistic over and over for every
combination and then your p-value is
just the number of times that a random
grouping of the target words produces a
test statistic that's bigger than your
original grouping so might be able to
see one yes yes exactly
so this is all partitions it's supposed
to be all partitions of to equal
groupings yes exactly
that's your original original grouping
so it's like one yeah that's on the left
on the right is the original test
statistic where it's the two group it's
that true original targets so one
problem with this you might see sticking
out is cardinality is going to explode
right because if you have a long list of
target words and you want to calculate a
test statistic for every every possible
combination of two equal groups yeah
that's gonna explode
so I tried it anyway it works pretty
good like my first attempts were very
slow I want to show a notebook let's see
if I can do that
oh it's not gonna let me here let's do
this there it is all right
so let's see I implemented we I did a
python implementation the first ones
were very slow but then I realized it's
doing the same comparison like you're
you end up doing lots of cosine
similarities like the same ones over and
over so you can memorize those function
calls and make this way faster and that
gets it to the range where you can
reproduce some of the tests that they
did in the paper and in that paper I
showed where they first defined we they
replicated something results from a
cycle psychological study or sociology
study in which they measured measured
implicit bias so they tested for racial
bias and gender and I wanted to see if I
could reproduce their results so I load
you a bunch of embeddings I used glove I
also used ad biased version of glove
that used the same concept net type of
device encode and then I use number
batch itself their version of it and I
used bulk BOCES hardly biased gender D
biased one and then I ran the same tests
that were in the paper reproducing the
original research and this plot shows p
values on the x-axis and effect size is
on the Y so the blue dot and the top
left corner is unlike normal glove
and the device gloves comes next number
Bosch did a little bit better all of
those had glove had an extremely
significant p-value and this the D
biased version of glove using the same
so using the same devising technique
that concept that used on their number
batch embedding it didn't work as well
as it did on their embedding so just
from differences in embedding even if
you use the same type of D biasing you
get different results and then way in
the bottom right corner is the word -
vectoring on Google News by Bullock basi
that used the hard D biasing technique
which I think was different than a
little bit different than what number
batch employed so this first test
compares gender to science and art and
you can see the target the targets up
here how they're grouped science words
or science technology physics chemistry
Einstein NASA and the arts are poetry
art Shakespeare dance literature so that
first paper I showed they didn't choose
this grouping it came from original
studies where they did this on people
and I was able to replicate the same
effects and significant levels that they
got both both in the paper where they
defined the word embedding test and the
original psychological study that they
confirmed so I think the implementation
works and I did get to compare different
embeddings and I got to play around with
different let's see if I can get
PowerPoint back
and I got to play around with different
devising techniques I ended up pulling
out all of the concept net code that
they used to be bias there embeddings I
took out all the dependencies and I'll
put it in the github page that link so
you all could play with you biasing
whichever embedding you want and the
wheat implementation is already up in
that github repo so the takeaways I got
from this was it works but it's it's
pretty noisy like if you test if you
then de by us like like I did glove and
or you take number batch and you try
specific examples of generating your own
analogies or just looking at like two
words and looking at the cosine
similarity to see which one's most
similar like what you do when you play
with Jensen and the word similarity they
make it really easy even with the D
biased embeddings specific cases still
gave really ugly results so my main
takeaway was you really need to
experiment with these embeddings with
text that is relevant to the task that
you're using it for and that's just
echoing what they said in those papers
above especially the first paper where
they define we it should really be used
in concert with other methods it's not a
cure-all at all it does help though I
mean depending on your task it can
definitely be worth it so so far we've
talked about building an intuition as to
why you saw those original examples
because it's based on co-occurrence data
not a complex I mean it's supposed to be
a complex understanding and code than
the embedding but and we've shown a
little bit about when it starts to
happen so I'm hoping you have an idea of
when you should be looking out for this
stuff and we started to talk about what
you can do about it
one thing is measure
you're embeddings with we and in the
context of how you're going to use it
and there's now a few a few tools that
you can mess around like playing with
making your own target groups and
testing for different types of bias now
I want to talk about what else you can
do because the majority of the past
couple months I spent researching this
stuff I found so many other things you
can do besides just using wheat to
measure and collapsing a subspace along
the dimension of a bias and I think this
this other stuff is probably even more
important so it seems like there's a
grouping that you can apply intervention
and the like to combat prejudice and
text data and it's at three different
points in a typical workflow so in this
first part we already talked a little
bit about that stuff and yeah really
knowing your data is going to help the
most like each of these embeddings has
its own warts the web crawl in
particular includes a bunch of
pornography and as Rob Speer pointed out
Rob Spurs on the concept net team and
made number batch words like girlfriend
teen and Asian have have a porn bias or
like their semantic meaning is actually
changed from what you would expect
because there's so much pornography in
the corpora in the corpora and that
corpus so that can that can also
implicitly bias other words related to
those words so you really have to pay
attention to which corpus you're using
to train an embedding know if you're
using pre-trained embeddings which ones
they use and how that relates to the
tasks you're using it for another a few
good tools for like searching through
large corpuses that i saw were flash
text which is basically a faster version
of regex
and it lets you add really long lists of
search terms and replace terms without
getting an increasing runtime another
good one is bouncer from the same people
that make jensen which is like a memory
bounded counter that'll give you
probabilistic counting over really being
like gigabyte size corpus another good
metric you can employ at this first
stage of I'd like a data project is
checking out gender pronoun gap and
that's just the ratio of the number of
times he appears compared to the number
of times she appears so just as a quick
overall metric on a big corpus of texts
you can quickly test for gender stuff
with a gender pronoun gap and people
have done that on Wikipedia so we talked
about testing embedding so we some of
the ways that people have tested
embeddings is we they generate analogies
so that bollock bossy paper instead of
using wheat they they used an embedding
to try and find analogies and then they
had Mechanical Turk or rape those
analogies as offensive or not and then
they they applied their method for D
biasing and then had them generate more
analogies after they D biased and had
the Turkish rate them again to figure
out what kind of effect they had that
was another strategy you can employ and
actually in that paper in the appendices
they showed they showed the form that
they give the example of the form they
showed to the Turkish it's like perfect
template for doing that for other types
of bias besides just gender so that's a
good resource other people like in Rob's
peers how to make a racists algorithm
Without Really Trying blog article they
trained like just really simple
sentiment classifiers so you can do
things not just looking at cosine
similarity but like training just a
simple positive negative
you can ask throw different text at it
like basically like that toxicity api at
the beginning and then i did see a
couple of like there's lots of other
formal mathematical ways to measure bias
a couple others i want to call out was
also embolic posses paper where they
define direct bias and indirect bias so
there there are plenty of ways you can
test embeddings now i want to talk about
steps you could take when okay you've
gotten embedding you did something to it
you're ready to train a model and use it
and most of these tools and methods to
work on like at this step and the
workflow focus on whatever the output of
the model is and trying to see if it's
fair between protected groups so there's
lots of great resources for this people
teach whole courses on what is fairness
that's a great one by maurice heart
there's lots of like there's a good
syllabus and material and that reference
for the course another good one to check
out is emily benders ethics and NLP a
couple packages to help you test
fairness and output again all the slides
will be posted I'm going to start
cruising now to get through the the rest
of the the methods you can employ this
is definitely good one to no you should
definitely learn about disparate impact
because that's one of the legal mandates
in the United States where there's an
80% rule of you cannot adversely affect
one group of people of a protected
characteristic more than another and
this is a great paper that talks about
how do you actually do that and there's
there is a github repo where some of
that stuff is from this paper is
implemented
this other source oh there's an arrow
Riley article about black box
interpretation and this article gives a
great overview of different methods and
when to apply them it's not written in
the context of assessing fairness or
unwanted bias but some of methods they
use you can apply to those two things
specifically and it's a great overview
one in particular is lime locally
interpretable model agnostic explanation
and for the Eli five package you get a
text explainer so for any text
classifier you can analyze the input
like one specific piece of input to a to
a text classifier and figure out why it
got classified one way or another word
by word alright now there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that's more
interdisciplinary that you can do to
fight bias in a workflow and two great
sources for info on this is Abe gongs
ethic for ethics for powerful algorithms
he's written a couple blog a few blog
posts on that and he gave a talk at
wrangle cough that went over it and
another one that just came out is the AI
now Institute's 2017 report there are
ten simple rules for a reasonable big
data research and it also amplified and
emphasizes that this is an
interdisciplinary problem and it will
take more than just technical solutions
to fix this type of stuff but it
actually gives actions you can take and
it's just important to really think
about how an algorithm can be
technically fair but ethically lacking
like when you're finished or preferably
as early in the possible process as
possible you should think about if your
algorithm even if it's fair who's it
beneficial to who is it harmful to if
you're doing a classifier what are the
consequences for classifications in each
one of each part of the confusion matrix
another another area to really consider
is how you market stuff because people's
the public's perception of machine
learning and algorithms in general is
they just don't have a good mental model
for for what it is so I think we need to
do better not overstating our abilities
and just to take one case study like the
perspective API if this was marketed
instead of toxic as just needs review I
think a lot of this could been avoided
and not to pick on the perspective API
people they've responded to this really
excellently they've published they've
published their analysis looking into
that particular case where all those
identity one's got toxic scores and
they've fixed the problem
they found a class and violence problem
in addition to using an undo biased
embedding so I recommend checking out
their analysis of what happened to it
also text in general outside of
embedding like you should have last-mile
filters if you're generating text for a
chatbot there's plenty of tools to help
you filter out bad words and there's
plenty of sources where you can augment
those lists to make them a little bit
bigger another thing you can do and the
deployment stage is give people a good
user interface that makes it easy to
report inappropriate stuff so here's
just google search results if you get
bad autocomplete there's a place I'll
place the log of complaint like if you
don't give people a place they'll go
right to social media so another thing
that we need to be better at is
accountability and these are just two
legal implications disparate impact we
talked about a little bit but the other
big one to keep an eye on is the
European Union's general data protection
regulation and that'll affect any
company that interacts with individuals
in the EU whether or not the company is
located in the EU that a inow Institute
report talks about
specific things you need to be aware of
within that as well so just to summarize
there's the three steps three areas of a
workflow and the things we talked about
in each and I think that's where I'm
going to stop so I can take a few
questions just a couple quick you talked
about two distinct analyses I don't know
I wasn't clear if they were distinct you
had the PCA does the PCA inform the
cosine PCA was used they were in the
mainly for that visualization so you
could visualize the subspace that
encoded the bias but it's also used in
the devising process when they're
deciding which words need the biasing
and which words are gender-neutral so
they train like a quick SVM or something
to say like go over the whole embedding
and you you give them examples of
gender-neutral words and non gender
neutral words if you're trying to do
gender and they use PCA to pull it out
okay you can check someone else I
noticed back in the slide where you're
explaining the D biasing where all the
words were sort of pulled to the center
there's a couple words still like left
on either side I was a curious like you
had to think an arrow pointing to like
the word president and one of the other
ones what what that was geez sorry those
super specific yeah no problem while I
look for and maybe I can take one last
question
the tock with lime in it is there one
here with is sweet today okay
3:40 Radio City today there is a talk
concluding lime so check it out
definitely that's a great way to do an
explainer anybody else so if I wanted
the biased I need a list of words that I
say these words shall be Center if I if
I don't know the language coming into it
is there a way based on just the
features of the text yes
you give them samples of the types of
word you want to be biased and that's
what I was answering the question before
is you train a quick classifier on yes I
want this D biased or no I don't want
this devised so it's gonna make errors
like this that other question sorry like
yeah I can't do the split screen thing I
don't think I'm gonna be able to pull it
up but that that other question he
wanted to look more at that screen that
I bendy bias that is from a paper
shocker body at all I can't remember the
name of it I'll sync up with you after
but yeah it doesn't work that that
classifier is not going to be perfect
like that in that de biased one it still
showed president as like super male and
policewoman was still good but that's
that's still encoded bias that was a
good example hold on the edges okay
thanks everybody
Mike we'll be around outside